The joe rogan experience are you?
Here's what you have to do.
This is my new theory.
Identify the vampire in your life.
Find The van Pyre.
Identify the parasite.
Doesn't have to be that
you have parasites in life.
It is possible that you could have gotten
lucky and there's no parasites and you
get off groovy.
Sure.
No,
I'm not saying everyone's got one,
but if you got one,
if you're walking around with
those fucking vampire blues,
you've got the fucking heavy heart and
you and you can't feel happy and you feel
bad,
there may be an action that you need
to take that you're afraid to take.
That's the vampire and you've
got to fucking not even a person.
Oh No.
I mean it's a situation,
a,
yeah,
it's a vampire in your life.
Find a life sucking situation
that you're afraid to kill.
And the reason I say vampires because
vampire is only go or they're invited.
And generally the
situation that you're in,
you invited it in,
you invited this thing into your life
and now it's sucking your life energy and
your blood and your happiness away.
Don't.
It's in.
A lot of times you'll try to believe,
you'll try to convince yourself
that this thing is not a vampire,
but in your heart,
you know,
you're a servant to a
fucking blood sucker.
Urn felt this thing is like
sucking your life as it's away.
Sometimes it's doing it with a trade.
Quite often there'll be a bad trade.
You'll be,
you know,
whatever the situation
you're in and you'll,
you'll,
you'll feel like you're in this situation.
You know,
it's worth it.
It's kind of bad,
but it's totally worth it.
This happens with jobs quite often,
you know,
or you're like,
well,
you know,
but it's good enough.
That's the vampires.
You got to take a fucking stake
and drive it into its art too.
How do you kill a vampire?
Two ways.
Direct Action.
You don't kill a vampire by
like making up with a vampire.
You don't kill a vampire by like
having a sit down talk with a vampire.
You're not going to be able to like,
uh,
you know,
make friends with the vampire.
There's two ways to kill a vampire.
One,
you fucking,
you know,
uh,
put a stake in its heart.
The other one is light sunlight,
truth,
light that it's the greatest
metaphor of all time.
You shine the light of
truth onto the situation,
fearlessly analyze it and
then you'll destroy it.
You know,
because if you really allow
yourself a few can act.
You got to add the real problem with
people is not recognizing the enemy.
It's acting on that enemy.
That's the real problem.
That enemy being,
you know,
personal,
your personal demons,
your,
your personal jihad.
That's a personal issue.
You got to fight the beast and it's,
and you know what I mean?
It's like everybody's beast is different.
Chapter two of the Bhagavad Gita.
Arjun,
as dejection arginine has
drawn between these two forces.
He does not want to fight.
He drops his bow and God says to him,
you've got rise to the fight.
Fight.
You're a warrior.
This is what you're here for.
Fight,
fight.
It's better.
It's better to die.
It's better to die in a righteous battle.
Then goes skulking off into the
fucking woods and be a beggar.
It's better to fucking do what you do on,
you're a warrior.
You got to fucking do it,
man.
It fucking sucks.
When when you're drunk and you want to
throw up and you try to not make yourself
throw up,
just throw up.
You'll feel better.
You'll feel better in the end.
When you're puking,
it's going to suck because you're
helpless and you can't breathe.
Go through it,
man.
Fucking jab a fucking knife into the foot.
Not Literally of course,
but yeah,
you got to act and you've got to make
the big fucking decisions sometimes.
And it's scary.
If it wasn't scary,
it wouldn't be worth anything.
Yeah.
For some people it's almost like
they don't know how to start.
They know that there's action that
they need to take in their life,
but they're paralyzed
trying to think about it,
trying to figure out how to start,
and they can never gather
up the courage to get away.
It's like what saw a lot of people
stay in abusive relationships.
They don't,
they don't have the courage to lead.
Exactly.
Cause it's scary and it in
it and it seems like it,
you know,
there's so many things that people
will like w ideas people will create,
they'll keep you trapped and whatever.
Prison,
urine,
it's very similar to um,
and not,
I mean,
what you're talking about in the
UFC with these fucking fighters,
this is a visual representation of
what anyone can do in their life,
but you're not getting,
maybe not all of us are going to get
obviously be worldclass fighters.
He in a ring in front of the entire
planet and fucking knock someone out.
But you have in your life right now,
if you haven't already done this,
there's,
you have the chance to be heroic.
You have the ability right
now to make a heroic act.
They could kill you.
That's the thing,
these actions,
it's not always guaranteed that
because you do the right thing,
you're going to end up in a great place.
You might end up fucked.
You might end up,
you might end up temporarily in a
homeless or you might end up temporarily
jobless.
If there wasn't risk associated with it,
you would've already done it.
That's the point,
you know,
if there wasn't a risk associated with,
it wouldn't be worth anything.
You know,
if Mount Fucking,
uh,
you know,
if the Himalayas where,
a little green grass
covered hill in a park,
nobody takes pictures of them at the top.
Putting a flag into what it is,
a danger makes it heroic,
you know?
So sometimes you just have to fucking,
I sound like Tony Robbins.
Take the leap,
kill the vampire in your life.
Kill the vampire in your
life is a brilliant speech,
dude.
Okay
son.
Oh Shit.
Itunes
according to server,
the fuck Outta here.
Server.